there's a Mongol hord coming into your
land right these guys are taking
everything and they will get everything
right if you and me fire over our stuff
well this guy's going to take all of
your stuff and all of my stuff it's
exactly what they want you know I'm not
saying that high owners should pay less
tax I'm not saying that high owners
should pay more tax I am looking at the
problem as it is the problem as it is is
these guys the very very very rich are
taking everything if you don't stop them
from taking everything then you will
have nothing and if you have nothing you
are poor like for me I speak a lot about
flows of wealth on the channel because
flows of wealth is how you identify who
you are losing to you know yes the
middle class is using their assets yes
the government is using their assets but
those assets are not being accumulated
in general by a guy earning 80 grand a
year they are being accumulated by
families with family wealth of 50
million 100 million quid those are the
guys who are accumulating the money and
if you don't stop them from taking your
wealth you will have no wealth